um what was the the the character that
was
the most difficult so far to kill off
uh for you and what was the the moment
uh that you have the most fun
to ride uh
the hardest character to kill off well
you know they're not really hard to kill
off
i swat them they die like flies
um you know most of the major deaths
have been planned since
since i began this series back in the
early 90s
um but sometimes things are hard to
write now of course
if you're just talking about the show
you've only seen a few major deaths so
far of course those of you who read the
books know that some other deaths are
coming the
the big uh sequence in the third book
um the the wedding was the hardest thing
that i ever wrote
um that was very difficult to do it was
the last thing i wrote in that
particular book even though it occurs
two-thirds of the way through the book
um i i had to skip over that chapter and
finish the whole rest of the book
and then finally when it was all done i
came back and made myself write that
chapter
because it was it was emotionally
wrenching
uh to write even as i know it was for
many of you to uh
to read um but that's the way i think
death should be
in in fiction
i mean too too often in in television
we use death as an act break and uh we
don't deal with the consequences of
death
uh if if you as most of us have have
experienced death in your family
uh the death of uh of a parent or
uh the death of a close friend or a
sibling or even
god help us a child you know how
hard that is and yet we see people die
all the time in entertainment
and we sort of gloss right over it and
get on with the action
uh and i don't i've never felt that's
right i mean if you're gonna kill
characters
you know it you you owe it to them to
make it hurt it should hurt death should
hurt it's it's the great our great
a great tragedy as human beings our more
mortality is central to our whole
experience here on earth
so i don't it's not something i take
lightly
and i try to make uh the deaths of
leading characters uh as powerful as
as they can be and the other half was
what was most fun to write
the moment that was the most fun
oh boy the most fun to write well i i
have a lot of fun writing tyrion's
dialogue
um it don't always doesn't always come
to me right away um
you know tyrion throws off these
witticisms
and i wish i could throw off woodisms
like tyrion but often it takes me
you know weeks to come up with the
things that he throws off at a second's
notice
in real life i'm very witty but i'm i'm
witty
late you know like two weeks two weeks
after the occasion
that's what i should have said and uh i
remember it but i can
i can do that with tyrion and i i like
it when a little little piece like that
comes together
that's fun thank you josh uh
i was just wondering uh peter dinklage
just just
blew my mind as a theory in in in the
first season and
obviously in the first first episode of
this season
has has any more actors actually
uh surprise you uh as as the characters
you created
because it's always so interesting yes
uh well
peter of course is amazing as he's
of course he's won the emmy and the
golden globe and the prestigious scream
award never forget
for his portrayal of tyrion lannister uh
and he deserves all of those awards and
many more i hope
there are many more emmys in his future
he's uh he's just sensational
and he was he was not our first choice
for tyrion he was our only choice for
tyrion
we did not we did not audition anyone
else
we did not meet with anyone else we did
not really even consider anyone else for
tyrion
we just went out and and made an offer
to peter and thankfully signed him
uh if he had turned us down um
i don't know what we would have done uh
it would have been uh very
very challenging because i don't know
there's anybody else in the world
capable of playing that role as he's
playing it
um
we have an extraordinary cast uh they've
all done very well
uh is there anyone who has surprised me
though
um i don't know i
in a sense i suppose all all three of
the principal children were surprises
they were the hardest roles to cast
it's really hard to find good kid actors
there are a lot of kid actors in the
world and
including in london and ireland where we
principally conducted our search for our
arya our sansa and our brand
um but most kids you know it's a great
it's hard for a kid to memorize all
these long speeches you know and
and uh you so you you get kids in and
they've memorized the lines
but that's all they've done you know
there's nothing they're not acting
they're just reciting lines that they've
memorized and i don't
i'm not trying to criticize for that
it's it's a great achievement for a
nine-year-old kid to to do something
like that but uh
that doesn't mean they can carry off the
role and then on the other hand you get
the other extreme you get sort of the
uh the the kid actor who has been taught
maybe he has taken a few
drama classes in school and he's been
taught that acting is all about emoting
so they emote all over the place they're
grimacing and
grinning and making faces and it's you
know you just want to tell them to stop
it you know
stop mugging for the camera it's way way
too much
and you know you look at hundreds of
these auditions and you begin to despair
of ever finding it
and then we find someone like maisie
with the minute i saw maisie williams
edition i knew she was arya
and uh david and dan all agreed i mean
she was she was just perfect
and sophie turner isaac hempstead right
there they're
doing amazing too and you know most kid
actors in hollywood there's a lot of
them on sitcoms that come out of
los angeles but all they have to really
do is be cute
and kind of get off a snappy one-liner
occasionally that
puts down the adults um that's the usual
sitcom formula
um our kids have to do a lot more than
that our kids have to convey
a full range of human emotions including
some fairly dark emotions like
grief and pain and loss
and fear um that takes serious acting
chops and we're very fortunate to find
uh
serious acting chops in those three kids
um sean bean was great but he was no
surprise uh
lena heady was great but she was no
surprise you know i could say that about
all of things amelia clark has been
amazing as daenerys i thought her scenes
and this one
were marvelous and the fact that she has
to
deliver half of her lines in a made-up
artificial language that no
actual human being had ever spoken
that's pretty impressive too
i know that let's see all your things
are subtitled here so
it was actually odd to me because when
she's speaking dothraki i'm used to the
english subtitles at the bottom
i couldn't read the portuguese subtitles
so that was the only part of the thing i
didn't understand but uh
but amelia is great uh another actor one
of our supporting actors who doesn't get
enough credit who really deserves it is
conleth hill who plays varys
uh god he is he's wonderful at varys and
he really has completely disappeared
into that thing i mean i saw his
audition when he was
he was still being conlethill and um you
know he's nothing like varys
you know you can see uh uh the the woody
allen movie that came out a few years
ago starring uh larry david
um if you see that he has a small part
in that
where he's one of larry david's friends
and take a look at him and you're seeing
uh
someone much more closer to real
commonwealth hill and then you see him
as varys and he's just become the
character and
there's no traces of of the actor
who was around there remaining so he's
pretty amazing
but i could go on all day i love our
actors i love our cast